[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
God bless you all who are watching right
now. We're here to have a discussion on
the Trinity. We have Jacob LDS Mormon
and we have Brother Avery from God Logic
Apologetics. These fellas are going to
introduce themselves. It's going to be a
great productive conversations.
Obviously, these guys are going to
disagree and it's going to be very
edifying. So, look forward to hearing
you guys speak and everybody's going to
be in for a treat. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Thanks a lot. So, go go ahead, Jacob.
You can tell us a little bit about what
you do. Um, your YouTube channel. Yeah.
And then, uh, I'll I'll say something a
little bit about mine as well. Yeah,
absolutely. So, uh, my name is Jacob
Hansen. I run a YouTube channel called
Thoughtful Faith. Just look it up on
YouTube, Thoughtful Faith. And I kind of
engage in Latter-day Saint apologetics,
but not only Latter-day Saint
apologetics. I also engage with
interfaith dialogues. I engage in formal
debates. I engage in sort of
philosophical discussions. So, it's kind
of a a full gambit of those kind of
things. That's kind of what what my
channel's about for sure. And so, uh you
also you got well known also from a
moment um on Jubilees channel. Tell us a
little bit about that. Oh, yeah.
So, so I recently was on the 25
Christians uh versus one atheist. And
being a Latter-day Saint, there's
obviously a little bit of controversy
around if Latter- Day Saints are
Christians. And I I totally understand
that. Um Alex picked me to go up and and
so I ended up not only having uh a
conversation with Alex within the
Jubilee debate like everyone kind of
did. I also had a chance at the end to
go up and have Alex sort of grill me. We
discussed the problem of evil. I kind of
did it from sort of a Latter Day Saint
perspective. And anyway, so it was a bit
of a it was a bit of a moment when I go
on Jubilee and I'm like, "Hey, I'm a
Latter- Day Saint surrounded by 25
Christians." They were like, "Uh,
really?" Like, I didn't I maybe it's 20
maybe it was 23 Christians or something
like that. Yeah. So, all those red flags
went up. Now, now with the rules with
that, if if all if you don't get enough
red flags, then you got to you got to
you get eliminated. Right now, I didn't
watch the episode, but I'm hearing about
this. So did they did you have to get
removed you know once you said that? So
the first round that I had with Alex I
don't think people knew that I was a
Latter-day Saint and I was debating the
question did Jesus claim to be God right
and so I think a lot of the I mean I'm
basically arguing very very similar to
to to you all um because ultimately I do
believe that Jesus claimed to be God.
Now, there may be some differences in
trinitarian thought that we have
differences on, but so I don't think
there was a lot there that people were
like, "Oh, he's a Latter Day Saint, like
let's get him out." Like, I think people
overall were cool with it. Uh, and then
the second time I went up when people
kind of I kind of let everybody know
like, "Hey, I'm a Latter- Day Saint."
That point in time, I couldn't be voted
out because Alex chose someone that I
had to sit there. I had to sit there for
10 minutes and it was I had to kind of
play defense. It was like Alex gets to
grill me and I have to kind of make the
case that I want to make for the
proposition that I gave. M M. And so
that's actually kind of a compliment,
right? So Alex gets to choose who he
wants to go at and he picked you. I I
assume that he picked somebody he
thought he was who he thought was
competent and could have a solid back
and forth maybe. Or he picked somebody
that he thought he could beat up. Oh
yeah, probably. Probably a little bit
so. Oh man. But that's cool though.
Okay. So now this is interesting. So you
do believe that Jesus claimed to be God.
However, you don't affirm the Trinity.
And so this is where this stuff gets
interesting. Yeah. Right. So obviously
the trinity you know one being you know
consisting of three distinct persons
father son and holy spirit co-equal
co-eternal in their essence. Um I want
to talk biblically about that if that's
laid out biblically or not. And so when
you have Jesus claiming to be God how do
you you know view that with the idea of
monotheism? So, and and I think I' I let
me see just to make sure because I want
to make sure that my understanding of
the Trinity is is accurate. I want to
kind of try and steal man it because I
don't want to I don't want to engage
with a version of the Trinity that isn't
kind of the best version of it. Okay.
And so, the way I look at it as the
essence of the Trinity is it's three
persons that share one substance,
essence or or nature, right? Mhm. Um and
so I and from a Latter-day Saint
perspective, we would view it like we
agree that Jesus is a fully divine
being, right? I I would use this this is
sort of the analogy that I would use and
maybe to clarify sort of the
distinction.
With my father, we both share the same
nature in that we are both human men.
Yeah. Right. We're both men. Yeah. And
so my father and I, we are both men, but
we are two separate persons. Mhm. So, we
share the same nature as men, but we are
separate persons. Yeah. And if that was
all that the trinity was, I'd be like,
makes total sense. Totally get that.
Rock with that. It's when the question
then goes to, okay, but then if someone
ever said, well, me and my father share
the same substance, then I'm going,
yeah. And my my genuine question and I'm
I'm really here just so everyone knows
like I'm not here so much to debate this
is to try and understand it. Yeah. And
and that's where I kind of am like well
what is that what what is meant by that
idea of the father and the son sharing
the same substance. Yeah. So so um I
kind of have a monarchial view of the
trinity. And so that's um the view that
the substance is like the father is the
source of the substance. And so you
have, if we're breaking it down, you
have the father and then he you have the
father's word and then you have the
father's spirit. And so this the son or
the word is eternally begotten from the
father's substance. So because he's
begotten from the father, he has that
same substance that the father has. Um
because the spirit is generated from the
father, he also has the same substance
as the father. So the father is the
source where who who is the one who's
beginning eternally and eternally
generating the spirit and the son or the
word. So that's that's the monarchial
view and and and help me understand the
difference between maybe the monarchical
view and then like alternative views of
it because I also want to make sure that
I understand because there's sort of
different variations on the trinitarian
view. What are some of the others
outside of that monarchical view? Well,
you'll you'll have some that just uh
they wouldn't necessarily say that the
father is the source of the divinity,
the divine nature. They would just say
that, you know, the divine nature is
made up of three distinct persons. Not
necessarily focusing on the father being
the source of of it. It's just you have
the divine nature and the father, son,
and the holy spirit share that share
that divine natur. So, so, so in this in
this view uh to to make sure I
understand in monarchical
uh trinitarianism, the father acts as
the source that feeds out to the others
rather than just being one of the
participants. Correct. So, he's in the
divine nature. Yeah. He he he um he
predicates the divine nature to the
other persons. So, because it belongs to
him, it's his and he's the one who's
beetting the sun. The son now has he has
the same substance as the father now
because this is an the beginning is not
something that happens in time. It's
it's an eternal action that's being
taken place. It's never done in time.
Right. So it's an eternal relationship
of of beginning and of of um aspirating
and generating coming forth out of
exactly out of out of him. And so and so
and and when you talk like the word
substance that's being used here, that's
one of the ones that and maybe it's a
little technical and difficult to sort
of nail these down to nail. Yeah. And
that that's maybe where I where I get a
little like I'm wondering like what is
meant by this idea of them sharing a
substance because when I think of
substance, I think of like substance,
right? Okay. And so if but the idea is
that God is immaterial. And so if God is
immaterial, I'm kind of trying to figure
out this um this idea of immaterial
substance and how those can can sort of
cross over. I guess it would be um a way
it's just another a word to try to
describe the the the I would I don't
want to say makeup, but just what God
is, what he is. It's the what he is. And
so the ontology, his being, his state of
existence. Mh. So his state of the the
state of existence that he is is divine
is you know God right all powerful all
knowing um necessary cause right
uncaused cause that's what he is now
when we're talking about you know who he
is that's where we're getting into the
nitty-gritty and we're seeing it's
complex there's a plurality within that
unity the who he is we see there's three
who's that you know share that same
substance I see so or divine nature
their being. So, yeah. And so, and and
see and I I look at it like and again
just from the father example that I like
to use like with my own father, right?
My father and I share the same. You guys
you guys have like nature. Yeah. We have
a nature that's similar, but but it
isn't enough just to say that God like
that Christ and the father share the
same nature. We're saying that they are
connected in a deeper, more fundamental
sense.
in substance and I guess that making
that distinction between what is the
distinction between someone having
sharing the same substance versus
sharing the same nature. I think I think
um like when you put it in human terms
like like we have like nature even you
and me yeah we have like nature right
we're we're both humans um but we're
different human beings right we're we're
separated by space and time we're
divisible God is not God is indivisible
you know not se so the persons that have
the same substance this divine substance
the divine nature they're not divided
they're not separated by space and time
which shows that there's that oneness
there's that one divine essence in
nature that cannot be split. So where we
have like nature but we're separated by
time and space, the father, son, and
holy spirit are not. So they can't be
separated. I see. And so and and so I
want to and one other aspect of that is
uh so like the idea of so Christ has two
natures. Yes. Hypoatic union, baby.
Jesus Christ. Hypothetic union. Exactly.
So,
um, one of the the aspects of that that
again trying to to understand it more
fully is that the,
um, the human nature and the divine
nature, I I wonder if there are aspects
of it that might be mutually exclusive.
Okay. Like um for example um to be fully
human right humans are by their nature I
would say are created beings. Mhm.
Right.
So can you be a human if you lack that
essential characteristic of humanness
that you are like you you you are
uncreated. Like there isn't a human
being out there that exists that is
uncreated. Yeah. And and maybe maybe am
I missing? Is it is that not an
essential characteristic of being a
being a human being is being I wouldn't
say that that's a necessary um essential
attribute of being human. It just
happens to be that we are created. I
see. I think that um you know just our
our soul, our makeup, our mind. Um these
are other things that more are that
determine what a human being is. Now
human beings they we are created. Um and
when you if you're talking about the
hypoatic union Christ's human nature was
created. It came into being. Right? And
this is there was Okay. So so so the
idea here is is that Christ's the human
nature part of his nature was created.
The human nature was created but the but
the divine nature part was not correct.
And so, but and this is one of the
things that again is is is like a little
puzzling to me that you don't you don't
affirm the hypothetic union. So, it's
funny. I actually
we I'm actually curious as to I'm not
100% sure on on that. Actually, it's
it's an open question that I have about
the nature of of of the way that we
resolve Christ's human nature and his
divine nature together. It's it's a it's
it's an aspect that I need to study
more. Okay. Um, and one of the things
with the uh hypothatic union and and
with the divine nature, it's kind of
like
if
I if these two natures are there, do
they conflict with each other? And I
know that the idea is they don't, but
like for example, omnipotence. Yeah.
Right. Or or or let's use let's use uh
um
uh not omnipotence. Omnian omniscience.
Yes. Omniscience. So I mean a person
being you is it possible for a person
one person within the trinity? Yeah. To
both have omniscience and then not have
omniscience at the same time. Yeah. I
think that so it's it's not that he uh
doesn't have omniscience but there's a
there's this idea of a veiling and so
where he veils some of these divine
privileges even some of the nuh the
knowledge in his you know subconscious
or whatever where he doesn't or his
human nature doesn't have necessarily
accessibility to um until unless the
father gives him the go-ahad right I see
and so um there's this view that you
know Christ like even the Bible says is
that the Bible says that he is veiled in
flesh and so and he he's walking in you
know limiting himself to human
limitations so submitting himself to
human limitations you get this view or
this picture that even when it comes to
knowledge he has all knowledge because
we see it we see him call out you know
um and and says hey your daughter has
been healed your son has been healed and
he not even be there you know um you
know go to and go get this donkey you're
going to meet a in there and just tell
him that the Lord needs it and he'll
give it to you. How do you know that? He
was never there. Never, you know, so his
and even the disciples say they say,
"Ah, now we know that you know all
things. You speaking to us plainly. We
know you know all things." And Jesus
says, "Do you now believe, you know, so
he affirms his all knowledge, but we
also see but he's human. How does this
work?" So there's there's there we we
see that he grows in wisdom and wisdom
and knowledge, you know. So it's like um
or he says that that there there cometh
a day uh or he says that you know the
time of the second coming knoweth no man
not even the son but only the father.
Now there's there's an interesting view.
Yeah. So so there's there's two views on
this one. There's this view the the view
of the veiling like he veils this you
know from his from his human knowledge.
Um you know kind of like how you have
knowledge in your subconscious that you
don't have access to. And so they they
there's this view that he veils that
right. And so according to his human
nature, you know, that's how he's
speaking, right? Yeah. Yeah. But then
there's this other view when you
actually kind of look more into the
language where it's he's actually not
talking about head knowledge. He's
talking about declarative knowledge,
meaning it's not for him or humans or
anybody to make known that hour, but
it's only the fathers. That's the
father's authority. Okay, I see what
you're saying. And so they'll he um he
even compares it like to a Jewish
wedding where it's the father that makes
known the wedding day. He compares this
coming to a wedding day. And so that's
the idea that he's saying that it's not
that he doesn't know his own coming, but
that it's not for him to make known,
it's for the father to do that. I see.
And it falls into that same the wedding
motif. Yes. Which is his it's kind of
the whole motif of his relationship with
the church. Exactly. And all that kind
of stuff. Exactly. Exactly. No, that's
that's great. And
um and and one thing is also the the
wills of the father and the son.
And the idea being that there are um you
know you have
the father and the son seem to have
different wills in scripture with sort
of like not my will that your will be
done. Yeah. But thy will be done. And
and I wonder how that works and and
maybe you can help me understand. I'll
try my best. And it's and by the way and
to those watching like I know this is
this gets into really heavy metaphysics
and ontology and it's and it's a it's a
complicated subject. So so please no I'm
I'm I I I'm very impressed that you've
been able to to just go through so far
because I know these are hard questions.
Um I with with the the dual nature of
the wills if they are one how can a
oneness and unity like that have two
wills? Yeah. So, so the idea is that
your will is based on your nature,
right? And so, um, Jesus and the father,
they have the same will pertaining to
their divine nature. And once the son
takes on a human nature, he has a human
will. And so, in this in this situation,
you see where Jesus in his human will,
it conflicts. But, however, he brings it
under subjection to the divine will that
he shares with the father. So, when he's
saying, "Not my will, but your will be
done." Yes. in his humanity, he has this
will that is weaker, that is fleeting,
right? Yeah. It's human. And so that's
that's how that's that's I see. So So
the idea is is that the divine wills are
aligned in one and they're not now. And
I don't know what your your kind of
feelings are around the idea of divine
simplicity and kind of that's that's
beyond my pay grade right now. Okay. And
that's and and maybe not because I
because I do know that some people and
and and maybe it's something that's for
a totally different conversation. But
the idea of that God is without any
parts. Yeah. Parts or passions and and
that sort of a conception of God um is
something that at least I I struggled to
a certain degree to reconcile. And maybe
maybe divine simplicity is not a
necessary condition of of the
trinitarian doctrine. I I I yeah I
wouldn't know like with divine
simplicity I have not studied that in
depth just yet so I wouldn't be able to
tell you. Um I'm pretty sure that other
people have some different views. I I've
actually heard of some a trinitarian
that doesn't think that divine like they
don't hold I guess to absolute divine
simplicity. They I think they hold to uh
some level of it but not absolute. So I
I don't need I don't know the
difference. And frankly and frankly and
that's totally fair because I know that
there are different there are different
schools of thought around the trinity
and and so where there's kind of the
monarchical one that you hold to or the
ones that others hold to like I don't
know that it's even a necessary
condition of it. Yeah. Um and and one
other aspect of it that that I've tried
to understand is um sort of the the
notion is is that within because God is
immaterial.
There is the ability for this um this
sort of hypoatic union. There's the
ability for this oneness to to exist.
And Jesus when he rises from the dead is
an embodied being. Yeah. With a
glorified embodiment. Yeah. Yeah. And um
and so the hypoatic union remains. It
remains. So this is so so and and maybe
this maybe this will clarify it. So the
idea is is that the human nature is the
part that is raised raised and
glorified. That is raised and glorified.
Yeah. I see. So that is the part that
is. Now what is interesting is is that
in the person of because some people
will say well God doesn't have a body,
right? Like that's a that's a refrain
that I hear. Yeah. But I guess in a
certain sense in the person of Jesus,
yeah, he took on a body and he and he
continues to have a body. He continues
to have a body. Yeah. To this day. To
this day. To this day. To this day. To
this day. And I've I've and I've often
wondered too like and I asked Trent Horn
this. We had a conversation on my
channel and and I'm not sure if there's
a difference between Catholic views on
this and and other Christian
denominations about like the status of
Jesus body like right now. If you have a
physical body, is Christ in some
physical place like in the universe
somewhere? Like Yeah, I think I think
that um just just uh you know, from the
people that I know and just biblically,
you know, it does teach that Christ rose
bodily and he was glorified bodily,
right? So, um he is in the spiritual
realms in his, you know, glorified body
living as our high priest, you know, at
the right hand sitting at the right hand
of the father. And so this is just
something that we will imitate when we
are glorified as Paul talks about that
we will also you know be changed and be
as he is right glorified in the spirit
realm be able to access the spirit realm
like he is right now. Um obviously now
in our unglorified corrupted state we
can't. Yeah. And so that that's yeah
that's that's with the hypoatic union.
It's it didn't just it stopped when he
died. Yeah. And that's and that's
interesting to hear. So, so in a way,
and maybe this goes along really well
with with the biblical teaching that
like he's the first fruits of the
resurrection, and it is his human nature
that is being glorified as sort of the
example to show us our nature will be
will be changed and glorified. Yeah.
100%. I like that. Yeah. So, so sorry. I
know I've been I've been the one. No,
this is good. This is good. So, all
right. So now with with this all being
kind of said, you you affirm that Jesus
claimed to be God, which is the most uh
you know interesting thing that I've
heard. Um so that going back to the
monotheism, right? How how do you
reconcile that if because you believe
that Jesus and the father are separate
beings? They're they're not the same
being. So how is that not two gods?
Yeah. And and I would and and I I will
answer that. I'm not trying to get
around it. I promise I want to say that
because there's the difference in
persons, right? Because you guys will
say that there are three persons,
correct? But one being. We will say
there are three persons with three
beings because we believe that to be
your own person, part of what it means
to be your own person is to have your
own being. Okay. Okay. So, do you see do
you see that? Yeah. But but you don't
So, like even with with the persons in
the in the Trinity, the Trinity view,
they have their own being. They just
share it. They have the same one being
that they that they own that they
possess, right? You're saying that they
have their own separate beings. So if
they have their own separate beings that
and they're gods that that's that that's
literally, you know, multiple gods.
Yeah. No, and I and I I I don't have any
problem saying that we're I would say
that we're henotheists or or
monolatrists probably. I know. No, I'm
just playing.
So, but I also would say that that is I
would say that the at least the earliest
uh biblical traditions when you go back
to them are if you look at the biblical
scholarship on it that the earliest
biblical traditions of Israel were
actually henotheistic. They didn't deny
the existence of other gods. They they
subordinated all gods to the most high
God. Right? Okay. And so and so within
our within our framework um we would
hold that the father acts as the most
high god right okay and so
um but we would say and there's also so
to understand our position I think the
it was funny uh in Bill Craig I'm a
massive fan of Bill Craig I've often
said if anyone could convince me to
trinitarianism like it would be Bill
Craig and so Bill if you ever see this
like I would love to have a conversation
Is Bill Craig William Lane Craig? Okay.
William Lane Craig was someone who
actually had a big influence on me when
I was kind of tempted by atheism and
then I watched him smack down
Christopher Hitchens and I was like,
well, I guess I guess I guess I'm not
going down that road. So, come out. So,
um he said once that Latter-day Saints
need to get get together their perfect
being theology. They need to figure that
out. And it's sort of like
we reject perfect being theology.
Perfect being and perfect being theology
is that where we start with the
definition of God is that of which there
can no greater be conceived. Okay.
Right. Got it. I believe that if you
follow that logic philosophically to
that of which no greater can be
conceived, it what it will lead you to
is to an abstraction. Okay. It will not
lead you and I believe that that
conception becomes incompatible with the
Bible. Okay. Um and I believe
that and and it's kind of a long story.
So, so we do not there's a
presupposition that's sort of underlying
this like you brought up monotheism like
that's the game. Yeah. Right. And I
would say that
if you the the hard monotheistic
tradition of God, this is sort of if you
go this this this by the way this goes
way before like the trinitarian
conceptions. This goes back to kind of
Aristotle's God, right? So Aristotle had
a conception of God where God was
timeless, spaceless, immaterial, the
unmoved mover, passionless, simple, all
of those all those characteristics,
right? Yeah. So I've always kind of
asked the question, why is it that the
God of the Christian tradition that
comes out in the credle tradition is so
similar in the description of God's
characteristics to the God of Aristotle?
Now, if I were to read the Old Testament
just straight up and someone were to
tell me that that God is passionless,
immutability, I would or I'm sorry,
impassibility, I would I would be like,
"Nope." Like, that ain't the guy in this
book cuz like he seems to have passions,
right? If they said that this God has no
parts, I would say, "Well, Jesus seemed
to have hands and feet and parts." But
now now but then again what you're
saying and I'm I'm kind of seeing where
you're coming from. You're saying that
in the divine part of his nature there
were no parts. Correct. Correct. But in
the human nature the human nature that
is where the the parts existed. And now
now that to me is is a very interesting
distinction to make. Right. And and I'll
have to obviously think think quite a
bit about that. Yeah. Okay. So, so
you're saying that biblically it it
leaves room for uh the existence of
actual other gods that actually exist.
Yeah. So, I would I would point to
things like the divine council in Psalm
89. Um where and now now people will
look at that and they will like I would
also refer people to the work of Michael
Heiser. I know that Michael Heiser and
and there are people that have been
gotten mad at me about this that I was
implying that Michael Heiser is not is
not a monotheist. He is like just
everyone knows Michael Heiser does not
go as far as I go with this but I agree
with Michael Heheiser's work that he
does point out that in ancient Israel
that they had this concept of a divine
council with other divine beings that
were called Elohim. Yeah. So, so would
but would they be actual like true gods
or are you just saying that they're just
divine beings in a not they're not gods
but they do have a you know they're
they're above the physical I guess
existence in a way and that's see and
this is where I want to point out it
depends what you mean by God see and
this is where the disconnect is right I
think just to understand the nature of
the disagreement because when you say
God you refer to that of which there can
no greater be conceived. The God of
monotheism. Yeah. And I say I'm not
making that assumption that that is what
God is. Okay. The God that's talked
about in the in the scriptures. So what
what what do you think it what do you
think God means when he says that um you
know besides me there is no God. I know
not one. There will be no God before
there is no God before me. Neither
should there be one after me. So when
God says there's no God before me or
after me, what does he mean by God?
Absolutely. That that is a and and
Michael Heiser talks about those exact
verses and I refer people to his stuff.
I have a I have a video on my channel
about this. It was a a response to Jeff
Durban uh around this subject. And
Michael Heiser clearly points out what
biblical scholars have shown that that
is a it's a Hebrew idiom for
incomparability. And we know that
because there are other verses in the
Bible where Babylon, for instance, it's
like who else is there besides Babylon?
It's kind of like saying like who else
is like me? like I it's a statement of
incomparability, not a statement of
non-existence. At least at least in the
scholarship that I've seen. Now, if I'm
wrong, like I would I would love to see
that that that the original authors were
talking about that. The scholarship that
I've seen has led me to believe that
that would be the the best exugesus of
the original thing is that this is a
statement of incomparability, not
non-existence. Because in other verses,
it does talk about this idea of other
gods. And I think what's being
established here and I and I agree is
that
there are other divine beings but it is
very clear that Yahweh occupies the
highest position amongst all divine
beings. Okay. So this this is getting
interesting. So and when when you're
when you're when you're talking about
the other divine beings or these other
like the Elohim, right? Which is which
is what the Hebrew word for God. Yes.
Exactly. And so you're saying that this
is used multiple times. It's affirmed
multiple times. And so in what context
do you mean Elohim? And so you're saying
that from your point of view, you know
that Yahweh is the most high Elohim. Um,
while there are other Elohim like in the
council or whatever that are they're not
what he is, but they are I would say and
I would say but see I would say that
they are all of the same species as
Yellow as Yahweh. Yeah. So, and here's
where we're going to get really wild.
Get this. So, I'm going to blow some
minds here. We're going to get we're
going to get really wild.
So, this this is where the heretic label
will definitely come down, ladies and
gentlemen.
But hey, I'm going to give it to you
straight. So here is where here is where
there there is a difference. Uh
definitely in our sort of theology that
we have. We do not believe that there is
an ontological distin like so within the
traditional sort of Christian framework
angels are a certain let's call it
species. Okay, demons are a certain
species. Okay, human beings are a
certain
species. God is a certain species. Mhm.
And there's an unbridgegable gap between
these species spec mainly between God
and like I'm never going to be a cat.
Like I'm just I'm not like different
species than a cat. I don't know. It's
2025.
It's true. It's 2025. You can be we are
we are blurring those distinctions fast.
Um but in in Latterday Saint cosmology,
there is no difference between angels,
demons, the human beings and God. They
are all part of the same species and we
as Christ would say to the people that
he said in the New Testament, ye are
gods referencing 189 Jews. Yeah. And and
what and and now now there's different
ways to execute those passages. Right.
And and I'm not here to debate that ours
is right. It's more just to say the
difference here is that in our cosmology
when we say you are children of God, we
mean it. It's not a this is not a
statement of you are children of God in
a sort of an adoptive sense. Although
there is a sense in which that that is
being made to those who are entering
into a certain kind of relationship with
God. But we believe that every human
being as it says in the beginning of the
Bible it says we will create man in our
image and in our likeness. But okay. So,
and so and and and I and I know there
there may be things you disagree. I I
have no doubt there's lots of disagree.
There's a ton there. What I just want to
lay out though is to understand to
understand the nature of the difference
between the positions is that
um we view all mankind as being children
of God. Like we what we'll say sometimes
is God's an embryo. And that God's
purpose is that we can become basically
the analogy he uses is like to grow up
to become if my ch if a child I want my
child to grow up to become like me and
enjoy all the blessings that I enjoy and
that is what our father wants. So we're
so you're you're going to you can be
like Yahweh one day. Exactly what Yahweh
is. Yes. This is the you can become as
God is. We can become we believe that we
can become gods. Okay. Now, now, but
there's a but there's a there is a
distinction though. Your father will
always be above you. Why though? Why is
it is it just in respect or is it
ontologically? Um, no. I would not say
that there's an onlogical goal. Right.
So, you're saying that ontologically by
nature your makeup you are you have an
equal value that Yahweh has. I would say
see this is and this is where again I
think there's a distinction to be made.
We don't view it in terms of like who's
like again perfect being theology is
very much about greatness properties
like who's the greatest of all the
greats and it's all about this hierarchy
of how high people are on this kind of
stat this this sort of greatness scale
let's say right where a latter-day
saint's conception of divinity and what
God wants us to enter into is a type of
life that he has that where we share in
it isn't about becoming Great. It's
about entering into a loving
relationship with God and with one
another into a perfect union with one
another. There's a there's a my favorite
scripture on this is John 17 where he
says to the disciples, he says, and I
encourage people to go read it. He says,
"Father, the glory that thou has given
me, I have given them that they may be
one." If we're talking about the oneness
of God, that they may be one as we are
one. And what I what our interpretation
of this is is that Christ is inviting
the disciples to participate in the
divine nature that he and the father
share. And the divine nature isn't so
much like I'm so big and strong. It's a
type of loving relationship that exists
between them. Okay. So we're That was a
lot. No, there's it's that's a lot. And
just so everybody knows like like we
have a whole different like we are in a
slight variation. This is why people
like I want to fully embrace like if you
want to say that well if you don't
believe this stuff that you're not
Christian I'm okay with people saying
that. All right. I'm not going to throw
it out the window. Okay. But I but I'm
going to say is is that that I would and
this is maybe something where where I
think if there is a debate to be had,
you know, that I actually would argue
that this sort of a conception and and
again don't we don't like we going to go
up a we ain't going to make it out here.
I would but but if there was going to be
debate, I am I am very interested or at
least exploring and or debating the idea
if this view that we have better aligns
with the Bible. Yeah, that's awesome.
That that would be I would love to see
that discussion. So, just a few things
to respond to uh just my thoughts on
everything you lay out. Okay. Like in in
John 17, you have the context of
ministry and Jesus is sending them out
to spread the message and he wants them
to be one as the father is as he and the
father are one in unison not necess not
in essence cuz cuz he says let them be
one in us as as we uh you know let them
be one in us you and me me and them and
that doesn't mean that they are now you
know uh some persons that have the same
nature as Christ and the father and the
spirit. And I and I I would say um I can
see that perspective. I can see how
someone comes to that within the context
of the ministry because that is part of
the discussion. I often point out too
that this is the final prayer that
Christ says before before the
crucifixion before he goes into the
garden and then to the cross.
If if he was gonna say something big
like that was the moment. And it would
seem and it would seem and it would seem
to me that if he's just like, "Hey man,
like Lord, please bless them that
they'll all be really good friends with
one another." But wait, do you don't
think it's big if he's saying, "I have
given them the glory that which you have
given me." Which that's a big deal. Yes,
it's huge. But in context, what is that
glory? Like we see it. Okay. So you have
the glory of Christ that the father gave
him on earth to work the miracles and to
do the miracles that he was doing. Like
in John 2 it says um and he performed
the miracle turned the water into wine
and then it says and he revealed his
glory in that context of miracle working
right John 14 we jump a few chapters
later he says whoever believes in me
will do the same works that I do and
even greater works will he do like in
quantity not quality guys so right
they're going to be also doing miracle
works the same things that he was doing
so that glory that he had in miracle
working power he's giving that same
glory to them and then he says the same
thing I have given the glory that you've
you've given me to them. Right? But in a
few verses later, he's praying, "Let
them I I pray that they come to where I
am so that they may see my glory." So,
we see a distinction of glories here.
There's a glory that Jesus had that he
shared with the disciples and then
there's a glory that they have to wait
to see when they go to Jesus's place.
Yeah. This is huge, but it ain't what
you're saying. Well, I'm not I'm not and
I'm not saying that the glory that he
gave them is the fullness of the glory.
Okay. I what what we would say is that
what he gave them is is you know as you
progress along this relationship that
you have with Christ and with God that
you will be divonized. Now okay within
if you actually want a really good
analog to this, it's the Eastern
Orthodox tradition and theosis. Okay.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Theosis. Their notions
their notions of theosis. I've spoken
with Eastern Orthodox. And by the way,
I'd be very happy to talk with Eastern
Orthodox guys to correct me on any of
shout out guys. He'll like to talk to
y'all. Yeah, I'm I'm down to do that. On
the subject of theossis specifically to
see where there if there are really
meaningful distinctions cuz I have found
that it basically is almost identical up
until like the last step. The last step
is they go you get to be you become like
God, but you'll never bridge the
ontological gap. Correct. Yes. And
that's we we go you do that. Yeah. And
you bridge the gap like you now are. Y
cross that line. Yes. We crossed the
line. That's wild though, Jacob. No, I
agree. I I I it's it's radical stuff. I
don't I'm not I'm not here to say it.
Like we have we have beliefs that are
significantly different, but I want to
point to where those differences come
from and where they're rooted in. I
would argue that those are rooted in a
particular presupposition of what we
mean by God and an onlogical distinction
between God and man that's
unbridgegable. So, but so this is it. It
comes from the scripture. Like you have
the scripture literally and not in any
metaphorical way. It's not God is not
playing games. He's literally saying
there I don't know of a God. I don't
know of no other one. Right? That's you
know like me. But there's no God like
me. There's not going to be there wasn't
one before me. There's not going to be
one after me. But you're saying yes,
there will be some after you. I would
and again I would I would point to that
as a statement again of incomparability
with I would refer people to Michael
Heiser's work on that. But you're saying
that we would be able to compare to him.
I Well, here's what I would also say.
There are also scriptures in there that
say that um ye are children of God. And
if children then heirs Yes. Heirs with
Christ. Yes. And I believe it also talks
about sitting on the throne with the
with with Christ and the father. Yeah. I
mean he's given us a certain authority
and a position. This is a now now I'm
not I'm not saying that there's I mean
there is a I think that there is a case
that can be made. Now maybe yours is the
better case. Maybe in in a debate like
that that would be the more convincing
of the arguments. You know what I'm
saying? But um there's no doubt even
within the Christian tradition itself
within within the Orthodox tradition
they can read it and at least come to
the belief that we can
become I mean they will use the word
like become gods. They they they won't
say that. Well, the early church
fathers, I believe, will. No. So, okay.
Well, and so and so and so it's like
they have a very strong view of theosis.
And and so the Latter Day Saint
tradition is very very similar. But I do
want I don't want to say that we're just
like Eastern Orthodox. We're not. I
mean, Eastern Orthodox, we don't cross
the uncrossable line, guys. We do cuz
like I I understand what you're saying
about theas and and you're like you
said, you're right to an like to an
extent when you cross that you you
bridge that Iraq, we cross the line,
guys. Sorry. Like, we we will be able to
when we're glorified, we're going to be
glorified. We're going to be joint hes.
We're going to partake in the divine
nature, right? But we won't have we
won't be ontologically the same as
Yahweh. That is that is I mean there's a
biblically that's blasphemous. Well, and
and and that's and that and you're I I
totally see how people come to that
conclusion. If they define God as that
of which there no greater can be
conceived, then it's an
impossibility for anyone else to share
in that because God is that of which no
greater can be conceived and there's
only one thing that is that of which no
greater can be conceived. So, so what
I'm pointing to is I I agree with you if
we start with the presupposition that
what God is is that of which there can
no greater be conceived. Okay? If if we
if we change this around just to kind of
see where the difference is because we
we don't define God that way. We define
God as our father. But this this my
thing when you're saying that it depends
on how we're looking at this. If we're
taking this position of the greatest
conceivable being, I'm arguing that
biblically that's how Yahweh presents
himself. Like he literally says, "Point
to something in creation. What is like
me? There's nothing like me. Nothing as
great as me. Nothing is high as me. He's
literally saying he's the greatest
conceivable being and even is beyond
what is conceivable. Right? So when we
see what Yahweh is saying and how he's
introducing himself and expressing
himself, he is he is introducing himself
as the greatest conceivable being while
at the same time being relational. And
so for for you guys to I'm saying you
guys, but You're good.
You people
to for you know for for that for you to
bridge that and say well or or say that
that's possibly an inaccurate view of
Yahweh and how we're viewing God. Um
obviously from my point of view it's
it's completely unbiblical. Oh yeah. But
you're saying there could be an argument
made for and I and I would I would agree
in the sense of of that I think that
there obviously can be and is a biblical
case made for that interpretation of the
text and that that's what the text is
saying. Okay. Right. And so I don't I I
um I don't fault people to be like, "Oh,
it's so obvious." I think that again and
and it isn't to debate right now, but I
think that there is also a case that can
be made to talk about God um as your
father in a far more
like
um yeah narrow or or or
a a closeness that's that's where you're
not like the the basic Latter Day Saint
view is that God is the father of your
spirit, right? And so there's a and
that's so this is a huge deal because it
says you're not a creature. You aren't a
creation of his. You are his child. And
that says something about your
potential. See, one of the other things
within Latter-day Saint theology is the
entire project. It isn't about like you
need to worship the right God otherwise
he'll like be upset with you. And maybe
that's a bit of a straw man, but it's
it's ours is about this idea of you have
a particular nature that it at its
deepest core is connected to divinity
itself. And the Lord created this plan
in order for you to reach the highest
potential that you have in you that you
don't even know you have. And so the
whole project isn't one of worship,
although worship is important and we
want to we worship the person who's
leading us to our divine potential. Like
that's kind of part of the process. But
that it is about
an eternal development of soul building
that can only be achieved through a
mortal experience that can take us to
another level of being. I see. And so
that's sort of the the the way that we
because it doesn't just it isn't just
like these statements about God are kind
of an isolation isolation. They have
bearing on what this means to us. Okay.
So all right. So la last area here. Um
you talked about the most high and you
you're saying that the father is the
most high. So obviously you you see
every other Elohim is lesser than the
father. in now is that in um is that in
ontology? Is that in what is that? I
would I would say in degrees of glory
and and intelligence and and power and
and and all of that. Got it. He will he
will always be above all of those. So if
you think about it, you know what are
angels? Angels are something like in our
in our view they'd be something like
like people who have not yet been born
or people who have lived and died who
are who are ministering to people and
and that's why like lost like your
relatives and stuff or almost like in a
sense like a guardian angel. We don't
believe in guardian angels per se, but
we do believe that our ancestors are far
closer to us, okay, than we realize. And
but all of these things when we talk
about angels or we talk about bad
spirits and evil sort of beings, these
aren't some other creature that's out
there, but they are fallen people that
that have evil and darkness inside of
them and they also are on the other side
of the veil and want to corrupt and
cause problems. Okay. So, so everything,
so much of it, so much of it comes down
to this idea of a different species of
being. And it's really gets wild and
weird when you say, "Hey, all of these
people or all of these beings, they're
all the same species just at different
types of glory." Okay. So, when you say
that the that the father is the most
high, he's the greatest, like he's uh,
you know, most powerful, you know, most
knowledgeable, everything, he's higher
than every every power. Mhm. Um you have
statements in the scripture that talks
about Jesus being exalted like Yahweh is
exalted. He sits on high next to the
father. Um he is above every power and
every glory and every you know
principality.
Um why don't you see Jesus as being as
high as the father when he sits on high
with the father and when you and and
that and that is actually a very good
question and a very good like issue to
to bring up. One thing that there's a
see a lot of this it's like we come from
it at a totally different paradigm. So
and there are different people that have
different theories about this. my
personal one that I enjoyed, by the way,
anyone who can get the chance if you
really want to read top level latter-day
saint theology. Um, I want to just plug
uh Blake Oler's book, Exploring Mormon
Thought. It's a four- volume series.
It's serious philosophical kind of
breakdown of these kind of things. And
Blake, his view of the idea of divinity
is divinity is a type of relationship.
Okay. Now, so the father and the son
share in the same kind of relationship
with one another of love. Okay? and they
are inviting us and and not only that
same kind of relationship of love with
each other but in relationship to all
things. My relationship with you is not
divine in the sense that it's on the
same level that the relationship that
the father has with the son. Right.
Yeah. But the idea is is that you can
enter into the divine life, the divine
way of being in the world. And that is
what that is what the fullness of
divinity is. What it means to be God is
to have right relationship with all
things. And what right relationship
looks like with all things is love. But
what makes Christ inferior to the
father? I wouldn't say that he is
inferior in in in the sense of he has
the same kind of like I guess the
question is well what's the scale we're
judging by? I believe that Christ has
all knowledge. I believe that he has all
power. I believe that he um and the
father share the same sort of divine
loving relationship with one another. So
it's sort of like
it it comes down to the scale that
you're using to sort of
evaluate difference between these
beings. So when you could you rightly
say then that Jesus is also the most
high along with the father. Yeah, I
would I would say that the see this is
one of the other things the way God is
used in scripture and I think this is
kind of a known thing. It can be used in
different ways. It can refer to divine
beings. It can refer to the trinity,
right? The triunesseness of of God. It
can refer to the father, right? So
there's different things that we mean by
it. Yeah. When I say it can also and and
in Latter Day Saint thought, the father,
son, and holy spirit, they're they're
separate beings, but we believe that all
three of those beings are fully divine.
Yeah. And so we believe because of that
because they're fully divine, they are
equal in that sense. But you made it you
you did make it clear that you're saying
that the father is the most high.
Actually, I I might want to backtrack
that. and and and and I want to I want
to just be careful about that because it
kind of becomes like a neoaranism and
I'm actually not sure if the Latter-day
Saint view
again depending on the scale we would
say that the father, son, and holy
spirit as a as a as what we call a
godhead rather than as the trinity. we
would say that that governing council of
those three is the most high like that
that trio is and you could use the word
instead of the word godhead use god just
because let's say that's the language
that a person has available to them and
we think that at times just like just
like Christians would sometimes say that
the word god in scripture yeah is
referring to the trinity we would say
that at times in scripture the word god
is referring to the godhead and I would
probably say and this is me kind of on
my feet trying to figure this
I would I would probably say that that
when I say the most high God, I'm
referring to the Godhead as a council of
three. Okay. So, as one unit. So, then
you would put Jesus and the Holy Spirit
with the Father as the most high
collective that that collective group
serves as the most high. Now, would you
say that they're together that they're
Yahweh?
uh how Yahweh is used and how Elohim is
used and how the angel the angel the
angel of the Lord right is the angel of
the Lord Jesus or is that yeah or that
does that mean Yahweh is the father and
then the I am like there are some really
like the Old Testament stuff the like
it's tricky to figure out like who they
referring to here right like that's
that's what we all have to deal with so
so if you ask me is is Jesus Yahweh it's
kind of like depends on the context I
don't know like Christians have the same
sort of issues Is it referring to the
person of Jesus when it talks about the
angel of the Lord? Well, we would we
would say as as Christians, yes. So, the
angel of the Lord, Jesus, he is Yahweh.
He's a person of Yahweh. Um, we'll say
we'll say that Yahweh is, you know,
multi-personal. He's the father, the
son, and the holy spirit. So, all three
persons can be identified as Yahweh. And
so that's why I'm like this this this
question is important because if you um
if you recognize
that there's three beings that are
collectively the most high. The
scripture does highlight in multiple
places. It it literally says in um I
believe it's Nehemiah it's Nehemiah
chapter 9 verse 6. It says you Yahweh
alone are the most high. And so with
your viewpoint, I'm I wonder how you
would reconcile that. I would say I
would say that that Yahweh can refer not
to a person but to a because you guys
believe also that there are three
persons. So I would ask it's sort of
like I feel like we kind of there's
almost a similar problem although you
guys have you can say well there are
three persons in one being. Yeah. And
the being Yahweh refers to that being. I
can see that perspective. I'm saying is
is that I think you can do the same
thing with this idea of the godhead of
that it's referring to the most high
three persons. Yeah. But uh so because
you you would also say that it's
referring to the most high three
persons, right? Yes. But one being like
so the most the most high and that goes
back and that goes back right to where
we were at the beginning where there's
this thing of okay Jesus is God, the
father is
God, there is only one God, right? those
kind of three things. Yeah. And from a
logical perspective, like there seems to
be a contradiction here because you
can't
have two gods and then be one God or
that they're identical to each other.
Like you said, it's it's how we're using
the term God. That's exactly. And see,
this is this is where um I would say
that with the Old Testament references,
it's using the word Yahweh or it's using
Elohim or it's even using the angel of
the Lord and those can all refer to a
person of the Trinity. I think we would
all agree there. Yeah. It could also
refer to the Trinity itself. Yeah. So, I
I agree. Well, except for the angel of
the Lord, but Yahweh specifically,
Yahweh it, you know, can be referring to
one of the persons of the trinity. It
could be referring to uh, you know, them
in their divine nature just simply as,
you know, the most high God, right? And
so, um, but the language that we see is
that it's so Yahweh is a being alone
within himself by himself who is Yahweh
alone, right?
Nobody else can be identified as Yahweh
and nobody else can be identified as the
most high and and and that so and I
think that's sort of like that's the
hard part because if you're saying
somebody else
well does that mean it has to be one
person? It means it's it's outside of
outside of you know the the three
persons that share the same divine
nature. See, and that and and that's
where and
so I would say
that when you're dealing with these
persons versus the being, is it three?
Is it one? I see that we have a very
very similar
issue with three persons because we both
agree with three persons. We agree with
three persons. But you believe three I I
do you well I I'll just ask you do you
do you believe that person and being
those words are interchangeable that
they I I do and I don't in this sense I
don't believe I believe like there's a
question what makes you a person like
what gives you your own personality. I
think to have your own being is what
makes you your own person. So I think
that it I I would argue philosophically
that there's a logical contradiction if
you were to say that me and my father
share the same being. It's like no what
makes me me and my father my father is
the fact that we have our own beings and
our own wills and our own okay would you
would you say okay so this so this is
how like remember how I describe being
is what a thing is all right it's the
state of existence so um like a rock for
example a rock is a being it has a state
of existence right it has a whatness but
we wouldn't say that a rock is a person
right it has no intellect
um and so there's This this is where we
see the distinction between being and
personhood. If we climb up the ladder,
we say, "Okay, there's human beings,
right? Each human being has one person,
right?" And so then we climb up the
ladder again, we talk about Yahweh, what
we're saying about Yahweh that he's one
divine being that has three persons. So
that's how we're we're making the
distinction. So and and I and and this
is where I get with that where I I again
it's like I kind of get my wires
crossed. I'm like I'm not sure because I
would ask like is there any example of
two beings or or I'm sorry two persons
sharing the same being sharing the same
being outside of the one exception that
we're making for for Jesus and the
father. If I can point to you if I can
point to you something and say or even
conceptually just just you don't have to
give me like a specific example. It's
more like even conceptually, are we
making up a category of this just to
accommodate this view or or can we point
to something that's like that? Let me
let me give you let me let me give you a
slight little thing here and it's not
like a perfect comparison, but you said
a conception. So in um in Genesis 2 and
in Genesis 5, you have Adam and Eve,
right? And um Adam and so Eve comes from
Adam. Yeah. But in Genesis 5, it says,
"And God named them Adam." They're both
Adam, yet they're two completely
different persons and they're two
different human beings, right? But
they're identified as one, like one
atom, right? One man. So um that's a
concept where we see a plurality within
the unity that you know when we get
climb up the ladder it's infinitely on a
different level when it comes to God and
his trinity and help me understand this
this climb up the ladder because I
understand like I would say again if
we're talking about a nature like a
unity and plurality like again you and I
we share we're both men and therefore
there is a unity but there's a plurality
of persons within that unity.
I understand that. That's that's not my
problem. So, if we climb up the ladder,
what I guess I'm just sort of like, what
ladder are we climbing and where does it
lead? Okay. So, there's you you and I,
there's multiple human beings, right?
With with God, there's only one of him.
And so, I know that you've expressed
already that you don't you don't believe
that. But this is the, you know, the
fine. Yeah. So, there's there's only
one, you know, one divine nature, one
absolutely divine nature, one divine
being. And and and I want to just to get
the clarification. I'm not trying to
nitpick. I just want to make sure I
understand because you said there's one
nature. I would agree like there is a
divine nature that like we have a nature
as men and you can have multiple persons
in it. So nature isn't the thing that I
have any issue with. It's more this idea
of substance. The idea of this is where
I and not I don't want to bring it up
like I have this big like issue. It's
more like this is where the disconnect
is for me because I have a hard time
understanding how can you have separate
persons that share the same substance.
They're not separate. That's the point.
There's the distinction, but they're not
separate. If they were separate, then
they aren't the same. They have their
own substance. I see. Right. But because
they're perfectly united ontologically,
they have the same substance. They're
not separate. They're just distinct. And
and how we
and and and and how we know the
distinction is we see you know the
operations of the persons. The father
begets the son that's the distinction.
The father generates the spirit that's
the distinction. The son sends the
spirit from the father. That's the
distinction right? So we see a
distinction not a separation. If we can
understand that and fix on that maybe we
uh we might we might get somewhere.
Well, I think I know I think I know the
direction that I need to start looking
and and and you've been you've been
great. Like you, too, man. I I
absolutely enjoyed this and we and we
could wrap it up here. This was one one
of my funnest conversations I've ever
had in my three years of doing this.
That's one. And but definitely out of
like the LDS that I've spoken to in my
life, you are topnotch. You like I can
refer you to some other people, believe
me. like there there's there's a lot
better than me. I'm I am often times I
often say this to people. I am very
often I am just someone who is
articulating things that these aren't my
sort of ideas and questions. When I read
people like Blake Osler, Terrell Given,
other LDS theologians and I explore
their work, some of the questions that
they ask, that's some of the stuff. So I
would I would refer people if here's one
thing I just want to kind of end on this
note. If anyone ever is going to engage
with el Latter Day Saints, if you go and
ambush a couple of missionaries that are
out there, you see the guys walking
around with white shirts and ties. All
right, I was one of those guys for two
years. All right. Now, now here's my
thing. I'm going to tell you guys right
now. It was probably cold in it back
there, though. I I I was in Argentina is
where I served. And I would say this,
those young men just graduated high
school. They are not theologians.
Their purpose is to be like a tour
guide. Are you telling us to take it
easy on them? Yeah, I'm kind of telling
you take it easy, huh? If you guys want
to go hard on somebody, I I got Hey, I
got I got stuff. I I got things out
there. I just want to say you're not
going to get the top level understanding
from those people. That's true. Okay.
They And it's like if I went and went to
just your average Christian teenager who
just graduated high school, like their
job as missionaries is to be tour guides
kind of to the faith. And so I would my
recommendation and I'm not if you want
to have a little fun and test their
scripture knowledge. I'm all right with
that. Just don't like don't post it
online and be like I owned an
18-year-old. It's like it's like bro
you're a freaking theologian. Uh so so
so take it easy on those young men. But
if you want to engage with the higher
level Latter- Day Saint uh thought
that's out there. Um there are great
resources out there. There are scholars,
there are theologians, and and I would
and I I'm happy to point people towards
who those people are. I would love I
would love that. I would love some like
resources and cuz what you was breaking
down, man, no LDS has ever broken, you
know, y'all's belief down like this in,
you know, this structured way. So, I
appreciated that. So, um yeah, guys,
this was awesome conversation. I hope
you guys enjoyed it. Make sure you guys
leave a like and subscribe if you
haven't done that already. All right.
Make sure you hit that like button like
you fear disobedience. Okay. 434. All
right. Peace.
It's God. It's God. It's God.
is God